لا عجب أنه غالبًا ما تكون ستائر فحص
الأمتعة
الملقاة على ناقلة
تتعرض للاعتداء من قبل أيدي الغرباء التي تبحث عنها ،
لذلك عندما قامت امرأة تمر
بمقبض Tick Tock في Giselle rochefort بنشر
Delta لتدمير حقيبتي ، كان أفضل ما
توقعته من Delta هو أنهم
سيحلون محل  حقيبتها المخدرة ،
لكنها بدلاً من ذلك تقول إن هذه
الحقائب وصلت 13 أرسلتها دلتا من
متجر يدعى ريكاردو بيفرلي هيلز ،
أعتقد أنهم ارتكبوا خطأً علق عليه أحد المهرجين ،
وهنا 12 حقيبة إضافية في حالة
كسرنا أكثر في الواقع تقول جيزيل
إنها وجدت المزيد.  اعتقدت أنني انتهيت فقط
من إدراك أن ثلاثة من الأكياس الكبيرة كانت تحتوي على
حقائب صغيرة بداخلها ، لقد
تواصلنا مع دلتا للحصول على
شرح ولكن لم نسمع مرة أخرى
في هذه الأثناء ، تتعرض جيزيل التي
لا يمكنه الوصول إليها للقصف ،
هل يمكنني الحصول على واحدة؟  أحب أحدًا ، هل يمكنني شراء
واحدة منك ،
ولهذا السبب تم تعزيز حقائب السفر الأمريكية ،
سيكون هناك
يوم ميداني مع كل هذه الحقائب التجارية الأمريكية القديمة السياحية ، لمرة واحدة
بدلاً من رسوم الأمتعة الزائدة ،
نتحدث عن جينيموس خالية من الأمتعة الزائدة
CNN
New York
[موسيقى]